Vladimir zielinski was welcomed in the
Netherlands one of his country's closest
supporters
his first appointment was at the
international criminal court
and he was quick to point out in a later
speech that he wanted to see action
against the president of Russia Vladimir
Putin we all want to see different
Vladimir
here
in The Hague
the one who deserves to be
sentenced for these criminal actions
right here in the capital of the
international law
and I am sure we will see that happen
when we win
and we will win on Wednesday zelinski
used social media to draw attention to
civilian deaths in the southern city of
her son hit repeatedly by Russian
Artillery
Ukraine says more than 50 000 war crimes
have been committed by Russian forces
since their full-scale Invasion last
year
Ukraine cities were also braced for a
huge overnight Air Attack that followed
What Russia said was a Ukrainian drone
attack on the Kremlin
nobody was injured but Russian officials
called it an assassination attempt on
President Putin a Kremlin spokesman
claimed it had been sanctioned by the
United States it could be a symbolic
strike Into the Heart of Moscow to
demonstrate that basically no part of
European Russia is safe from a Ukrainian
attack and obviously attack on Kremlin
has a lot of symbolism considering that
on May 9th Russia is supposed to hold a
massive Victory Day Parade there
President Putin was back at work on
Thursday picking over the country's
economic performance showing that it was
business as usual for him
however President Putin tries to portray
the explosion over the Kremlin
difficulties are mounting up for him as
stalemate on the front line a looming
Ukrainian counter-offensive and
president zielinski at the international
criminal court in The Hague threatening
prosecution Charles Stratford Al Jazeera
Kiev